- Your new album,
it's a bit of a throw back
to your early days, right?
- Yeah.
- Okay. So what does this mean?
Is this like stuff you wrote
like in your early days?
- Yeah. That's what happened,
you know, when you're,
when you're doing your well,
your first, my first three,
four albums before I had children
and had a life, you know?
I used to, you know,
just write all the time
when I was all at home
and on the bus.
And so I had a bunch
of songs and, you know,
you only put 10 on an album.
So I had some leftover and a
few years ago, I went back to,
I was maybe going to do
a box sex didn't happen,
ended up changing management
and going off my record label
and everything.
But I had recorded these songs a few years
ago that I had written 30 years ago.
And it was really exciting
because they were, you know,
I'm no longer, you know,
I'm the only one, you know,
I'm no longer broken
hearted thank goodness,
I'm much healthier and
have a great relationship.
So I'm not writing those songs.
So it was great to go back
to when I was and pull
those songs out and kinda sing
with that rock feeling again,
pull them up.
So if you like that older
stuff, this album, and it's the-
- I think a lot of us liked it
- You know, you know, its okay
(audience clapping)
So this album is filled,
filled with songs like that.
And the one I'm going
to play for you today
is right around the
"I'm the only one" time,
you know, it's like, really, it's rockin'.
- [Kelly] Oh my god I love that.
And there are so many songs
people don't realize that we all write,
and then they don't make
it just because whatever,
for whatever reasons,
a lot of it's politics.
- Well, yeah, well,
a lot of these songs that are on the album
were very feminist based
and very kind of strong.
And this is 1989, 1990,
and things were really
different back then.
And I just sort of said, well,
maybe not this time for that.
And then they faded away.
- [Kelly] Perfect now!
So perfect! It's like
not a problem at all now.
- Agreed. Agreed.
- Yeah.
Was writing different for
you back in those days
before you came out? Was it harder?
- Harder.
- Or was it more clever? Did
you have to be more clever
about it?
- Exactly it focused
it because I wanted to,
I wanted to write what was
really going on, you know,
I wanted to write personally
and what was happening,
but I didn't want to "oh,
she's that lesbian artist."
You know, I'm only singing about women.
- [Kelly] You don't want
to be boxed in one thing
- Exactly. So I learned to be
non-gender specific, you know?
- Which is also very now.
- There you, also very, indeed!
- You were ahead of the times!